okay i look like i'm sitting in some
generic
therapist's office that's fitting tis
the season
[Music]
oh no thank you for cara for supporting
today's video we're going to get into
that later but first
hi my name is grace helbig if you do not
know now you know your life is different
now welcome to a video
this mug has never been more appropriate
weird holidays the holidays are upon us
whether we have
realized it want it are sober enough to
understand it's happening
weird year huh weird year means weird
holidays which means whatever
traditional rules we had for gift giving
in the holiday season
they're [ __ ] gone gifting this
holiday season is gonna be a little bit
strange
everyone is going to have to accept your
gifts this year no matter how
terrible or wonderful they are because
they're truly gifts
this year and with that that means that
you can get away with giving some crazy
[ __ ]
to the ones you love and those you know
that you feel obligated to this is
all over the place classically i tried
to make a plan and
you know like we've learned this year
plans are great plans
don't always go as planned we'll see
where this video goes so my favorite
types of gifts to give
have become very diy centric i think
it's a great gift to show people that
you care
it's also a hilarious gift because
you've seemingly done
and poured so much time and energy into
a gift and they have to accept it no
matter
how awful your artistic ability is
if you have triple a awful artistic
ability
this is your time to shine so let's
start with the diy types of gifs over
the years i
have graced my family disgraced my
family with
various diy gifts first idea i have for
you something i did for my family a
couple years ago i made them all
personalized denim jackets which in
theory
was super cute and very unique and in
practice
was very time consuming and the results
were
very unique so that's one idea last year
i found a website that made these
personalized like
bowler shirts kind of like these retro
button-up shirts
and you can put your face into designs
that they've already created
and man were they a hit i love them so
much and i gave them to all of the
members of my family
some of elliot's family that i met for
the first time a real
way to welcome yourself into a family
huh in hindsight
oh they're a little bit narcissistic if
you're self-aware about it does that
curb the sharp edges of the narcissism
let me talk to my therapist about it but
you can put whatever you want on those
shirts and the reality was that the
quality of them was undeniably really
good so there's some ideas for you did
you know that the internet
gives you opportunities to personalize
just about watching everything
if you didn't know wow get on there ask
mr jeeves wake him up
time to work i gotta put my face on
something that my family
will be forced to struggle with throwing
away when i'm not around
in that diy realm here are another
couple gift ideas that i
just scrounged together with things i
found in my house or things
i found at a craft store for very cheap
and maybe if you like these you can
figure out a way to personalize them for
you we've probably all gone through our
houses and we've downsized or gotten rid
of a lot of [ __ ]
and sometimes you can upcycle that to
give back to the ones you love this
holiday season you're probably not gonna
be face to face with them this holiday
so you don't have to see
the disappointment and confusion when
they open it that's a win we're trying
to be positive about all this first idea
i have is a pillow pal a couple years
ago i also found
these boyfriend pillows online that are
just pillows with like an arm wrapped
around them that are kind of sad when
you think through the general idea of it
but it's basically a pillow that you
could sit with on the couch to make it
feel like someone's got their arm around
you
and did i get that from my brother for
christmas yes i did but here's an easier
way that you can do we're all missing
each other this holiday season right so
if you have like an extra throw pillow
or any kind of pillow laying around
there's this scum pillow i've had for so
long that should be thrown away but this
year
it's getting gifted you take an old
shirt or sweatshirt that you have laying
around
very apropos and we're basically to wrap
this sweatshirt
over this pillow and you can sew up the
bottom if you want
i would maybe use some velcro so you
could get it off easier you can also
fill the sleeves if you want to give
some real like body mass
effect in there and there you go now you
have a pillow pal
that for your family that has missed you
all year long they can still spend some
time with you
on the couch see look how cute quirky
like urban outfitters throw pillow kind
of fun
right also i recommend using an item of
clothing that hasn't been washed so it
really has your essence
just baked into it cute next okay for
the next gift idea all you need is a
pair of dirty socks and what you do is
you put these
in a box and you send them home to your
parents
you tell them scatter them on the floor
to remember what it was like when you
lived at home and you had dirty socks
scattered everywhere
it's the perfect gift it's the gift of
nostalgia
and that's priceless cute next coasters
i bought these at the craft store for
like i don't know a couple bucks the
amount of times i've gotten coasters
as a gift for christmas is a lot i have
so many coaster sets in my house
and i don't use them so why not give
someone else a coaster set to deal with
but because these are a little birchwood
kind of situation we can draw and
decorate on them so i thought we'd draw
just inspirational words on them really
try and make them cute
okay and just with a little sharpie and
some creativity we have some really cute
coasters this one says i'm trash
which isn't offensive because you assume
that they're not going to use the
coaster
so you could assume that this is the
coaster's point of view oh here's a nice
one
it's dread o'clock why and now you give
the gift
of a set of emotional roller coasters
cute next this is a gift idea slash like
a holiday decorating idea when i went to
the craft store
i saw these ornaments and they have the
little hole cut out in the front there's
tons of these clear plastic ornaments
and you can make all kinds of
personalized things with them you can
put in
like change that you have sentimental
things like pictures
your kid's teeth that fell out the
placenta from your baby snacks
i thought if you want to personalize it
for family members or a loved one print
out a picture of your face
and then we are going to cut out some of
the features of my face to put in these
decorative tree ornaments christmas
doesn't have to be
that sad of a time it's a real time
where we're all
adapting it's an opportunity to really
flex your creative muscles
once you've got your little photos in
your little ornaments you ship them to a
family
member or loved one that you can't spend
the holidays with you ask them to put it
on their tree and then bam
you're home for the holidays with them
or e.t is home for the holidays with
them
i it's a thought that counts cute and
not at all haunting
next okay this next one is for people
that may have had
a moment this year in which they
exploded emotionally onto you
and it turns out it was more projection
than it was actual
targeted emotional anger pain
sorrow whatever it might have been
that's a long-winded way of saying this
year is
up all of us in a variety of different
ways and
you might have had exchanges with
someone that you love that has put you
guys in an awkward
place so why not this year give the gift
of forgiveness
by giving that loved one a pass
this is basically to say i know that you
had an emotional burp and you blew it in
my face
wasn't cool but i love you i understand
that we're all trying to get through
this the best way we can and therefore
you get a pass we can move forward i
honestly think this one's pretty great i
think we should normalize this i hope
that you
uh get inspired to perhaps give someone
in your life this this year or receive
this
this year it's like a light-hearted way
to move through some pretty deep
trauma dude next you don't want to diy
something let's move on to some free
options that you can give someone that
are
very unique and will also help fill that
void
of not being able to see each other for
the holiday one idea is to turn your
phone onto audio record
for one day straight just record
everything you do all of the talking to
yourself
talking to other people just walking
around farting folding clothes
making lunch all the things and then
take that audio recording put it on a
cute hard drive
and send it to your loved ones so they
can feel like you're around for the
holiday have them play
on their speaker system and then wham
bam thank you ma'am
you're farting around your family for
the holidays another financially
responsible idea
if you really want your loved ones to
feel like
they have you this holiday season
with them if you've kept a diary this
year or a journal
or any sort of thing either print it out
make copies of it or just package up the
actual notebook itself with all your
wild
untamed thoughts and send that home for
the holidays
that's the most personal gift of all and
your family will really feel like
they've spent some time with you and
they can't say that they're upset that
you're not around
they might actually respect that and
understand and think it's better that
you guys are not
with each other for the holidays now
let's move on to some actual
practical gift ideas here are some ideas
that i've used as gifts last year that i
think worked really well
and you can take them or leave them
boxes humans
love boxes we love the mystery
of something that could potentially be
extremely helpful in our life
but probably it's just gonna be a bit of
a burden
a sweet burden but a bit of a burden in
addition to the narcissistic button-up
shirts that i gave everyone in my family
i also tried to get them like
subscription
based box stuff so that i didn't have to
bring as many physical items
home in addition to the 30 shirts or so
i brought home with me
also because we don't know what 2021 is
gonna bring we might be stuck inside for
a lot longer than we think
so why not give your loved ones the gift
of activities they can do inside last
year i ordered for
a couple my family members craft boxes
that show up once a month where
it's a designated craft every month you
have all the parts in your box
and you can make it i have not heard
from them on whether they've made
any of the 12 crafts they received last
year but i'm gonna
assume that no news is good news i also
gifted a family member an escape room
box this website makes
basically like escape rooms in a box
that you can do from home and they send
them every month or every other month
which was super cute and i think very
fun
we all feel like we're living in our own
little personal escape rooms so
why not really nail that point home is
this sad or uplifting
very profound question this year liquor
subscriptions
i gave my stepmom a tequila of the month
subscription last year every month she
got a cool looking bottle of tequila
she loved it she sent me photos that i
think is a great idea for people there's
wine clubs there's
any kind of booze that you could imagine
there's a club for it donations
across the board i think we're going to
be doing that a lot in my family this
year
donating to either a charity of your
choice of their choice i think is
always an incredibly thoughtful idea
especially this year no sarcasm attached
to that one and in line with like
subscription boxes and that sort of
thing
i'm throwing in care of as a gift idea i
love them very much
i take my vitamins every day and i think
this is actually a truly great idea for
a gift for someone else or to tell
someone else to get you hair of a
wellness brand they help you meet like
health goals that you have and they
create personalized
vitamin packs tailored just for you
they're formulated with good for you
ingredients they're backed by
science have you heard of it quite a hot
topic this year i'm into it i hope you
are too all you do is you go on their
website you take their five minutes like
lifestyle quizzes ask you questions
about your lifestyle your health goals
the things that you are concerned with
on a personal level and you can get as
specific or as generic as you want it's
basically like getting a one-on-one
with a nutritionist online through a
quiz from the comfort of your own home
and then they'll give you
recommendations based on how you answer
the questions on the quiz and you can
decide to take the care of
specialist recommendations or you can
customize a pack
however you prefer and with the seasons
changing winter is upon us it's good to
think about your immune
health plus i think it's kind of cute if
you do get this for like someone else
like your mom or
your dad or an aunt or uncle grandparent
and they don't really know
how to fill out the quiz you can fill it
out with them
online and then it's kind of a nice
bonding experience that you can hear
like what they're concerned with what
they
want vitamins for and then helps you
keep tabs on them in the future just
saying
have i done that with my family no but
could be a great option to explore
i use carob literally every day that's
why this box is running low sometimes i
put little like inspirational quotes on
it this one just says how's it going
you tell me carol is this video any good
and if you're interested in care of you
can get 50
off your first order by going to take
care of dot com and using the code
graceh50 it's not saying that you're
unhealthy here help you it's saying like
hey
you might not have thought about this
this is not invasive and also just very
healthy and cute and i care about you
but if they get upset you can also pair
it with like this
and just see what happens were there any
other ideas i'm missing out on oh
yes someone had dm me a while ago saying
that they make personalized vibrators
and so that is
something that you could do you could
put your face on a vibrator for your
loved one
oh god well there you go there's grace's
holiday gift guide
some inspiration some diy some just
plain
why but hopefully you can be inspired by
enjoy
and give to the people you love and
secretly hate the most this holiday
season i hope everyone's being
responsible wear your masks when you can
masks are also obviously a great gift
idea oh or gloves oh this was the other
one just a box of gloves you don't
really need to say anything else with it
just a box of gloves i mean if someone
gave me a box of gloves for christmas
i'd
i that would be great i already have a
box of gloves for any of my family
that's watching this video so i don't
need them one of you might be getting
one of these that's it that's the whole
thing those are all my ideas if you have
any please leave them in the comments
down below like this video
give it a thumbs up don't forget to
subscribe and make videos
when you least expect them thanks for
watching i don't know
i understand that a lot of these gifts
are
laced in sadness but i think that's my
specialty is trying to find
the silly sweet sarcasm
in the suffering and the sadness that is
taking place this year
like i do with anything that upsets me
emotionally let's move on quickly